the unsealed indictment offers a
stunning look at the allegations against
the former president including images of
America's deepest Secrets carelessly
stored in a ballroom a bathroom and a
shower at Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago
estate are laws that protect National
Defense information are critical to the
Safety and Security of the United States
and they must be enforced special
counsel Jack Smith is unequivocal that
Trump was not allowed to possess top
secret and classified documents after he
ceased being president he's now charged
with 37 counts including conspiracy
making false statements and a staggering
31 counts of willful retention of
National Defense information for keeping
documents concerning America's nuclear
weapons foreign military capabilities
and top secret White House briefings we
have one set of laws in this country and
they apply to everyone it's called
election interference they're trying to
destroy a reputation so they can win an
election Trump's fiery Thursday night
offensive was quickly overshadowed there
are allegations he twice showed
classified documents to people who were
not authorized to see them there is an
audio recording of at least one instance
these are very serious charges and
they're also the kind of charges that
are likely to be particularly easy to
prove the conspiracy charges allege
Trump and his aide Walt NADA moved
documents so they would not be found by
investigators even after the Department
of Justice issued a subpoena for their
return there are multiple text messages
phone calls and conversations including
evidence provided by Trump's own lawyer
that Trump asked his legal team to lie
this is information that could cause
extraordinary harm to the United States
uh government and to our national
security if it's disclosed publicly it's
important to remember that it was a
grand jury made up of ordinary citizens
that voted to indict Trump based on the
evidence if he is ultimately convicted
he could face up to 100 years in prison
his first court appearance is set for
Tuesday in Miami